le conseil départemental de la réunion
vous présente lien social le conseil
départemental aux côtés des réunionnais
la création du café des aidants traduit
la volonté du département de soutenir
ces acteurs invisible que sont les
aidants familiaux
le gip et maison de l'aide à la personne
ainsi mis en place un partenariat avec
l'association française des aidants et
le conseil départemental pour
l'organisation du concept le café des
aidants un concept labellisés au niveau
national les aidants familiaux jouent un
rôle primordial
pierre angulaire du maintien à domicile
ils sont des publics qui souffrent et
non pour la plupart pas eu le choix
il porte une lourde responsabilité et
sont confrontés à des difficultés
le café des aidants est là pour leur
apporter des réponses et à certain répit
comment fonctionnent les café des
aidants à la réunion on en parle tout de
suite d'un lien social les café des
aidants sont des réunions des changes
animé par une psychologue et un
travailleur social destiné à des
personnes accompagnant un proche en
perte d'autonomie ou en situation de
handicap
le café des aidants se déroule
actuellement dans deux secteurs à la
casse grand air à l'antre-2 dans le sud
et dans le nord à l'espace raid l'est à
saint-denis de structure créée par le
département
d'autres vont également voir le jour
dans l'ouest l'est et dans le sud
sauvage
ces espaces sont propices à
l'information tels que l'accès au droit
les lieux ressources les démarches à
accomplir et bien d'autres encore animés
par des équipes de professionnels
trouver des réponses et des clés pour
mieux vivre sa situation voilà ce que
recherchent jacqueline boulevard et
dante pour sa fille handicapée dans ce
café des aidants et le fait de
participer à ces café des aidants
ça me donne personnellement mais le
courage la force de continuer 2
suivre ma fille pour pouvoir valider
dans ses gestes quotidiens
on a quand même des thèmes qui sont très
intéressants et qu'on aborde eux
avec une psychologue qui avec nous et
qui nous donne quand même des conseils
donc je peux vous dire ce sont des cafés
très enrichissant que je conseille aux
autres et d'en devenir de venir
s'instruire venir participer
pour moi c'est une joie de venir au café
des aidants c'est toujours avec un
plaisir que j'attends les chats noirs
ce café des aidants parce qu'on peut se
rencontrer avec d'autres vers d'autres
aidants comme moi donc on se rend compte
que chacun a ses difficultés que nous
partageons ensemble ça fait trois ans
que
que ça a été mise en place et que je
suis tous les mois autrefois on était
chacun de son côté et ont essayé de
traiter comme on pouvait ses problèmes
ses difficultés
et maintenant que nous sommes ensemble
et je dirais que nous sommes mais dans
la main avec nos problèmes donc on
essaye de résoudre nos problèmes pendant
deux heures on n'a peut-être pas une
réponse définitive mais en a quand même
des petites intuition pour pouvoir
avancer avec nono aider au café des
aidants
il ya ce qu'on appelle le répit repos
nous les aidants mais on est un peu des
fois même si je dirais surchargé on a
les épaules très loi dont a besoin de
souffler et grâce au répit repos mais on
peut souffler cgu
séjour au vvf de trois jours c'est très
très reposant sa bouche elle vous n'êtes
pas la maison dont votre idée est avec
vous mais ça fait une sortie et après
quand même quand vous quittez ça fait
quand même souffle nouveau
ils ont aussi la possibilité d'avoir
comme une auxiliaire de vie qui vient
chez vous ou à garder votre jeune et
donc ça vous libère la maman ou de papa
sow fait celui qui a la garde de son
jeune pays peut aller faire ses courses
et pendant ce temps il ya quelqu'un qui
s'occupe de votre adultes porteurs de
handicap mais principe du café des
aidants c'est vraiment un rendez vous
mensuel qu'on fait aux aidants puisque
ça s'adresse aux aidants de tout âge et
toute pathologie qu'importe la
pathologie ce rendez vous mensuel permet
à ces personnes de se rencontrer
d'échanger le grand principe ce principe
de la convivialité puisque son nom le
patron du café des aidants c'est bien
sûr au toit d'un café que ça se passe ce
groupe de parole les modalités des cafés
donc on part sur une séance déjà de 1h
il ya une présentation d'un thème ça se
passe toujours avec un thème et sur les
questions très techniques
donc le travailleur social peut faire
une orientation ou même avoir un rendez
vous avec cette personne et concernant
l'aspect émotionnel
on a bien sûr la psychologue qui est là
donc pour on va dire canaliser toute
cette charge émotionnelle est aussi
prévoir des consultations individuelles
si c'est demandé à la demande des
personnes
c'est un thème qui devient un petit peu
moteur pour faire démarrer ce groupe de
parole ça fait un an qu'on existe et la
fréquentation des cafés donc on a une
grille
isation badia global à peu près 250
personnes qui ont participé à ces cafés
saint denis on parlera plutôt d'une
participation fidéliser avec un noyau
dur de personnes douze personnes
fidéliser mais on va dire 70 personnes
qui ont au moins participer un café sur
sein d'une accompagner un proche l'aider
à accepter et à vivre avec sa pathologie
ils sont près de 60000 aidants qui le
font quotidiennement pour un membre de
leur entourage
à la réunion nous aurons certainement à
le faire un jour de notre vie afin
d'éviter l'épuisement c'est café des
aidants sont précieux ils permettent de
prendre du temps pour soi pour mieux
prendre soin des autres
soucieux de ses publics vulnérables et
dépendants le département vous donne
rendez vous au jardin de l'état le
mercredi 11 novembre pour la journée
départementale des personnes handicapées
et le samedi 14 novembre pour la journée
départementale des personnes âgées
ensemble continuons de créer des fonds
nécessaires pour le vivre ensemble
le conseil départemental de la réunion
vous a présenté lien social
le conseil départemental aux côtés des
réunionnais